position russe en vue d'une résolution
du conflit la fin de l'élargissement de
l'otan à l'aise propositions et vision
soutenue par la chine en marge de
l'ouverture des jeux olympiques d'hiver
auquel il a assisté vladimir poutine
s'est entretenu avec le président
chinois xi jinping une déclaration
commune a été publié dans la foulée des
détails avec maelys d'estrées
le sommet chine aussi organisé ce
vendredi à pékin a confirmé que les deux
pays sont plus soudés que jamais lors de
sa rencontre avec six gym ping vladimir
poutine a mis en exergue l'esprit
d'amitié et le partenariat stratégique
qui unissent leurs deux pays une
alliance qui transparaît également dans
le communiqué publié ce vendredi par
moscou et pékin ils exposent leur point
de vue partagé sur plusieurs dossiers y
compris l'extension de l'otan les
parties s'oppose à l'élargissement de
l'otan et appelle l'alliance atlantique
a abandonné les approches idéologisé de
l'époque de la guerre froide à respecter
la souveraineté la sécurité les intérêts
des autres pays ainsi que la diversité
de leurs modes civilisationnel culturel
et historique
pékin réitère son soutien aux
propositions de moscou visant à établir
des garanties de sécurité en europe une
fois de plus russes et chinois rejette
l'idée d'un modèle démocratique unique
les tentatives de certains pays
d'imposer leurs normes démocratiques à
d'autres de sa tribu le monopole
concernant l'évaluation du niveau de
conformité aux critères démocratiques de
tracer des lignes de séparation sur des
bases idéologiques sont en fait un
exemple de piétinement de la démocratie
et de dévoiement de son esprit et de ses
vraies valeurs pékin et moscou dénonce
également jeu cycle influences négatives
pour la paix et la stabilité dans la
région de la stratégie indo pacifique
des états unis et se disent préoccupés
par la création de locus l'alliance
entre les états unis le royaume uni et
l'australie tant dans leurs paroles que
dans leurs écrits la russie et la chine
font ainsi front commun face à la
thalassocratie anglo saxon et ses alliés
occidentaux